66 für alle die auf dieser woche sind
wir uns und du bist der nächste baum
altersskala hat seine periode und sagte
du kannst mir gar nichts sagen
was ist los bei dir du bist mein gott
jo leute herzlich willkommen zu einer
krassen krassen krassen runde momente
chamber ob diese krasse wissen wir noch
nicht mit dabei ist der einzige rapper
minecraft useless servus die verlegte
leben alter was sagt die verlegt ihr
leben so hart du warst einfach keinen
bogen
das kein boden bekommen zu sein
verpacktes leben ich habe keinen bogen
alter
ja klar der champion mit bogen und skill
und alles ohne witz ist das ding für
mich kein klassen auswählen
überhaupt was ist los bei dir du bist im
falschen spiel egal
als ich will zeigen wie mach jetzt
einfach mal judo wie gesagt also ich hab
keine freie runde da wird noch eine
runde
das heißt keine katze kein zweiter
versuch und wenn dingsda hat in der
falschen runde ist dann machen uns einen
spaß draus und in der nächsten runde
wird er dabei sein
ich schaue dass hier jetzt mal ein
bisschen was reister bin auf platz eins
dort läuft eigentlich muss jetzt nur
noch halten
die ssri bugs juni kleiner musik tipp
formieren gebt euch auf jeden fall
juni von rick ross richtig fett als
fahrgast in letzter zeit so hart den
habe ich entdeckt also wenn ihr republik
gerade so kanal ok sap oder so dann ist
es wahrscheinlich auch das richtige für
euch
richtiger baba ja so wir haben noch
wieviel leben noch zwei leben und wissen
auf platz eins das ist natürlich ein
muss sagen die runde geht an mich wenn
ich jetzt nicht dumm anstellen ja
den habe ich getroffen
ok dann habe ich auch getroffen 13 kills
noch ein leben das nicht mir jetzt
keiner mehr
42 noch 17 sekunden noch 17 sekunden
und das obwohl so richtig hat verlegt
initiieren alter und dient ja vor mir
und dann sind wir auch immer hinter mir
und macht gegen winken
die ist das okay ich hab die runde
geworden wir machen einen cut sehen uns
danach wieder und dann ist er liebe hieß
es auch auf stadt so meine lieben leser
und zuschauer hat sind wir auch bei mir
wieder zurück in mein bett folge und ja
bei mir als mister matt hughes ist der
erste nicht geschafft hat china
spielmodus reinzukommen
ich hoffe jetzt ist da drin und es
scheint es scheint so als wäre drin
wurde nicht rausgekickt das an sich ist
ein kleines wunder aber auf jeden fall
diese alter diese krise
diese hunde kinderalter wie kommen sie
jetzt gibt's kills gegenargument neun
unbesiegten scheiße den pvp alter jetzt
gibt es sex besser bad sex für alle die
auf dieser woche sind - und du bist der
nächste
beim alter was und kanada
art of fucking hell leiter hat heute
seine legen tage periode
du kannst mir gar nichts sagen ich lag
halt ein bisschen so ist es halt in der
verriet nein ich sage heute ich hab
gerade eben schöne street gemacht sagt
bin so von vom berg runter gekommen
scharapowa und hab mir ein bisschen die
kills weg ist net und java business
nackt und den hab ich nicht gesagt
vielleicht zeigt in dem pvp nach capri
nein das war nicht der fall noch zwei
leben junger platzierung marseille
kriegt den kommentar
ja das kommt davon dass ich mag
überhaupt man spiele sondern eher sowas
wie league schaffen
die fleet of legends
ja geil das war ein richtig auf mit lex
max immer noch der bbb der gern genick
bricht schaut dann revier für diesen
über kassen spruch und ich bin wenn sie
die firma naja ging so ich muss mal
schauen was hier abgeht also in den
letzten tagen scheint ein bisschen
probleme zu bereiten
wie gesagt also hat gewiss tier hat
seine tage und dann warten wir werden
ein paar tage ziehen uns zurück lassen
ihr viel schokolade essen oder sie ihn
dann geht es vielleicht besser mit
diesem bild callwey schmeiße
verabschiede ich mich zum abschluss noch
zwei worte nein mehr als heute
zum abschluss noch wenn es euch gefallen
hat dann lasst ein ballast ein abo da
und auf jeden fall bei dem herrn in der
beschreibung vorbeischauen news lässt
wie gesagt er mache nicht nur minecraft
er rappt auch und beide ist ziemlich gut
wobei ich noch denkt dass er besser als
mein kopf macht und wie gesagt vbt war
auch schon dabei also grasser typ und ja
in diesem sinne check die beschreibung
geben auf seinen channel wenns euch
gefällt und nike da lassen und ja dann
macht's gut leute haut rein und knecht